we begin with another historic day in
american history
unfortunately we have heard those words
many many times here on
cbs this morning today president trump
could soon become
the first president to be impeached
twice
this time on a startling charge of
inciting an insurrection
last night the house voted to demand
vice president pence use the 25th
amendment
to force president trump out of office
pence is refusing so impeachment
proceedings will begin
just hours from now and there are new
signals this morning from senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell that he
may be
open to impeachment nancy cordes is in
washington nancy good morning
good morning that's right leader
mcconnell has told associates that
impeachment
could help the gop move past president
trump and that
could completely change the dynamics of
the senate trial to come
over on the house side gop support for
impeachment is growing by the hour ahead
of today's vote
a member of republican leadership is now
on board
she calls it a vote of conscience
there has never been a greater betrayal
by a president of the united states
those are the blistering words from the
third ranking house republican
wyoming's liz chaney who says she will
vote today to impeach
president trump she'll be joined by at
least
four other republicans including john
catko of new york
to allow the president united states to
incite this attack without consequences
is a direct threat to the future of this
democracy the house is set to pass
one article of impeachment incitement of
insurrection
arguing president trump encouraged his
supporters to obstruct the electoral
count
and the peaceful transition of power
adding that his actions
resulted in the terrorist attack that
occurred last week
nor did he swiftly denounce the violence
last night house democrats made a final
and ultimately unsuccessful attempt to
urge the vice president to invoke the
25th amendment
never before as the president sought to
overturn a fair
and secure election the president's
actions demonstrate
his absolute inability to charge the
most basic and fundamental powers and
duties of his office
therefore the president must be removed
from office
immediately many in the president's
party will vote against
impeachment again everybody in this
country knows that they wanted to
impeach president trump on his first day
in office
it looks like they're going to want to
impeach him on his last day too they're
going to do impeachment
they're going to do it again they've
been obsessed with it
the president is arguing the same the
impeachment hoax is
a continuation of the greatest and most
vicious witch hunt
in the history of our country in texas
yesterday he took no responsibility and
claimed there was nothing wrong
with the speech he gave just before his
supporters stormed the capitol
it's been analyzed and people thought
that what i said was totally appropriate
but today's impeachment with its
high-level republican support
suggests otherwise and the impeachment
process
is now moving so swiftly that last night
house speaker nancy pelosi
named the nine house managers who will
argue the case
in the senate trial in the last
impeachment it took her nearly a month
to name the managers it's the clearest
possible sign
that she plans on sending this article
of impeachment to the senate for a trial
right away tony yeah here it comes nancy
there are new security measures on
capitol hill understandably but we're
hearing that several republican
lawmakers actually angry about them
what can you tell us that's right
tensions were very high at last night's
vote
on the house floor between house
republicans and democrats and even
capitol police over a new security
measure that requires everyone going
onto the house floor
to walk through metal detectors that
made
many republicans very angry some of them
refused to comply
including a new member colorado's lauren
bobert who has vowed to carry a gun
everywhere on capitol hill she was
spotted
arguing with capitol police over
searching her bag
democrats say this is for everyone's
safety but republicans argue it's an
atrocity
and unconstitutional tony it does seem
prudent nancy thank you very much